Both Harley Quinn and the Birds of Prey have
a not-that long yet pretty storied history
in the DC universe, and the Margot Robbie-led
flick pays tribute to both if you're paying
attention.
Birds of Prey is all about Harley Quinn's
big breakup with Mr. J, but the Clown Prince
of Crime isn't Harley's only ex.
As Birds of Prey's animated prologue explains,
Harley's heart was broken a number of times
before she hooked up with the Joker.
However, Harley's one true love isn't a homicidal
clown.
It's Poison Ivy, the botanist turned eco terrorist
who's proven to be quite a thorn in Batman's
side.
In the comics, Harley and Ivy are a very popular
pairing, and Birds of Prey knows it.
That's likely why the female face that turns
up on the prologue's cartoon slot machine
looks a heck of a lot like Pamela Isley.
While it's not definitively Poison Ivy, it's
pretty obvious that Harley has a type.
Birds of Prey isn't a direct sequel to Suicide
Squad, the movie that introduced Robbie's
Harley Quinn to the big screen, but it clearly
takes place in the same universe.
While grocery shopping with Cassandra Cain,
Harley recaps her story, and summarizes the
events of her earlier film.
A few shots from Suicide Squad reappear in,
or were recreated for, Birds of Prey, when
Harley flashes back to her origin story.
That connection opens the door to one of Birds
of Prey's best Easter eggs.
While breaking into the Gotham City Police
Department in order to free Cassandra Cain,
Harley catches sight of a "Wanted" poster
on the wall.
You might recognize that man if you've seen
Suicide Squad.
The man on the poster is none other than Jai
Courtney, who played Harley's teammate Captain
Boomerang in David Ayer's superhero flick.
The DCEU may not be as interconnected as the
Marvel Cinematic Universe, but little links
like these are always nice, especially considering
that Boomerang is expected to come back in
James Gunn's upcoming Suicide Squad film.
With a name like that, how could you expect
anything different?
"What the hell's wrong with you people?"
"We're bad guys, it's what we do."
Cassandra Cain plays a big role in Birds of
Prey, but she actually plays an even bigger
role in the comics as one of Batman's many
sidekicks.
She's been Batgirl, a superhero codenamed
Orphan, an assassin, and one of the deadliest
women in the DC Universe.
Cassandra Cain first appears in Batman #567
as the mute daughter of a deadly assassin
who raised her only to, quote, "speak the
language of violence."
That's a pretty comic book-y concept, which
is likely why the film makes some major changes
to the source material.
In the Birds of Prey movie, Cassandra is a
hard-luck pickpocket with a rough family life
and a tendency to attract sympathetic older
female mentors.
She ultimately ends up as an "apprentice"
to Harley Quinn, sporting a similar look and
an identical love of breakfast sandwiches.
Considering that the comics have seen her
eternally passed over for a larger role in
the Bat-Family, maybe the DCEU's version of
Cassandra Cain made a better choice.
After all, "Harley Quinn's kid apprentice"
is still a better codename than "Orphan."
"It's got a nice ring to it."
When Renee Montoya comes by Dinah's apartment
to ask her to be her woman on the inside of
Black Mask's organization, Dinah refuses.
Black Canary tells Renee that she remembers
that her mom was a hero who was left to die
with no help from the police.
While that's a pretty convincing reason for
anyone to stay out of the superhero spotlight,
Dinah's superheroic mother is a reference
to one of the most confusing retcons in DC
history.
Black Canary was one of the very first super-heroines,
and a central member of the Justice Society
of America.
Eventually, the Justice Society of America,
along with Black Canary, were retconned to
exist on a separate Earth from the regular
DC Universe.
Later, they were re-retconned into the main
universe, and the modern Dinah Lance was reimagined
as the daughter of the original.
Birds of Prey wisely errs away from multiversal
hijinx in its runtime, but it seems that,
no matter the universe, Dinah's mother was
always a hero.
Helena Bertinelli's character arc in Birds
of Prey is arguably the simplest.
When she was a young girl, her parents were
gunned down by a crew of mobsters led by Stefano
Galante.
That's a pretty dead-on adaptation of her
comic book origins one of them, at least.
In her most famous comics origin, Helena's
family is gunned down an assassin working
for a group of rival mobsters, most notably
Stefano Mandragora and Junior Galante.
The movie combines these two mobsters into
one, presumably to keep the number of onscreen
assassinations within a slightly more manageable
scale.
"Psychologically speaking, vengeance rarely
brings the catharsis we hope for."
"Yeah."
When she debuted in Suicide Squad, Margot
Robbie's Harley showed a lot of skin.
Instead of the black and red long johns that
made her famous, Robbie's Harley sported hot
pants, a short, sparkling jacket, and a t-shirt
with "Daddy's lil monster" scrawled across
the front in faux -cursive script.
Some fans loved the new look.
Others found it sexist and needlessly objectifying.
Even Robbie seemed mixed on it.
She told The New York Times:
"I'm not wearing hot pants next time."
Still, that Suicide Squad look is iconic on
its own and Harley can't escape it entirely.
In the animated prologue, Harley's wearing
her original Suicide Squad getup.
Her old outfit pops up again later in the
movie, when Renee Montoya is looking for something
to wear.
However, even when Harley is dressed entirely
differently, the Suicide Squad influence remains.
If you look carefully, you'll notice that
Harley has a tattoo on her chest, which also
says "Daddy's lil monster," just like her
old shirt.
Without Harley Quinn, we wouldn't have Birds
of Prey.
Without the Joker, we wouldn't have Harley
Quinn.
And without Jerry Robinson, we wouldn't have
any of them.
While Bill Finger and Bob Kane get all the
credit for creating Batman, it was Robinson,
an artist, who invented the Dark Knight's
archnemesis in 1940.
Joker isn't in Birds of Prey, but his influence
looms large over the film.
As such, it's only fitting that Birds of Prey
pays tribute to Robinson's legacy.
When she's captured by Black Mask and his
goons and pleading for her life, Harley tries
to convince Roman that she's good at finding
things.
As an example, she brings up a nude photo
of Eleanor Roosevelt that the Joker once had.
When the scandalous picture went missing,
Harley managed to find it in a bird's nest
in "Robinson Park."
Played by Rosie Perez in Birds of Prey, Renee
Montoya is Gotham City's toughest and smartest
cop... even if she can't stop talking in '80s
cop movie cliches.
Originally appearing in Batman: The Animated
Series before making the jump to comic books
in Batman #475, Renee's long been a fan-favorite
character and an important member of Batman's
supporting characters.
Viewers don't get to spend a whole lot of
time getting to know Renee in Birds of Prey
before the craziness starts.
Still, there are some nods to Renee's most
integral qualities; most notably, her sexuality
and knack for superheroic mischief.
Ali Wong appears in the film as Ellen Yee,
Gotham City district attorney and an ex-girlfriend
of Montoya's.
As far as we can tell, Ellen is an original
character for the film, but Renee's mixed
business and pleasure before she's dated Batwoman
in the comics, and former district attorney
Harvey Dent had a longstanding, one-sided
obsession with her.
In Birds of Prey, Renee ends the film saying
goodbye to the GCPD and joining the titular
superhero team; although she doesn't take
a codename on screen, she's worked as a successor
to the Question in the comics, which seems
as good a codename for Montaya as any.
In one of the most relatable moments in the
film, Harley tries to get over her breakup
with the Joker by buying a wildly expensive
pet that she might not have the time, money,
or space to take care of.
Slightly less relatable is the fact that she
chooses to buy a vicious hyena.
Harley names the hyena Bruce, in a pretty
clear reference to Gotham City's most eligible
playboy billionaire, Bruce Wayne.
However, what seems to be a spur of the moment
decision for Harley is actually a deep cut
reference to the character's long history.
In the cartoons and comics, Harley's often
seen with her two pet hyenas, Bud and Lou.
Even though Birds of Prey changes some details,
it's pretty clear that Harley without a hyena
pet is like Batman without his bats.
She's also got Bernie, a taxidermied beaver
wearing a tutu.
The entire movie is so wacky that it would
be easy to dismiss Bernie as just another
piece of zany set dressing, but the stuffed
beaver is actually a popular recurring character
in Harley Quinn's own comics.
As the story goes, Bernie originally belonged
to Harley's first crush.
Young Harleen stole the taxidermied animal
when her boytoy was sent to juvie.
Like in the movie, the Bernie of the comics
is dead, but since Harley's certifiably crazy,
she treats him like he's alive and able to
speak anyway.
Fans of the Injustice video game franchise,
which pits DC comic book characters like Black
Canary and Harley Quinn against each other
in Mortal Kombat-like fights, have found a
few similarities to the games in Birds of
Prey.
During one scene in Birds of Prey, Harley
dresses up in a stylish coat and hat in order
to sneak into the GCPD, where Cassandra's
been locked up.
Her outfit looks almost exactly like one that
Harley wears in Injustice: Year Two.
There's even a near-identical shot in which
Harley tears her coat open, revealing heavy
armaments underneath.
It isn't just Harley who gets the Injustice
love, though.
Black Canary does, too.
At the climax of the movie, Dinah Lance finally
unleashes her sonic scream, decimating the
Black Mask's goons.
It's a big moment, and it should look familiar.
Jurnee Smollett-Bell, who plays Dinah in Birds
of Prey, all but admitted on Twitter that
she based her pose on Injustice's version
of the Canary Cry.
Birds of Prey doesn't have a full post-ending
sequence, but it does have a nutty little
treat for fans willing to stay in the theater
until the lights come up.
As the final credits roll, Harley's voice
takes over the soundtrack.
First, she makes fun of the audience for sticking
around even though the movie is over.
Feeling some pity for her fans, however, Harley
decides to let everyone who's still in the
theater in on a little secret: "Batman f—."
And the audio cuts off before Harley finishes
spilling the beans.
We don't know exactly what Harley was going
to say, but we do actually have a pretty good
guess.
On the Harley Quinn cartoon on the DC Universe
streaming service, Harley made headlines for
suggesting that Batman has a very... intimate
relationship with the flying mammals he takes
his name from.
"I always wondered what the batcave looked
like.
So this is the place where you f--- the bats!"
It sounds like Robbie's version of the character
was going to let moviegoers in on the slanderous
truth, too.
Yikes.
No wonder Warner Bros. cut the audio.
"Well, a guy who dresses up like a bat's gotta
have issues."
Birds of Prey has a few musical interludes,
but there's only one that serves as a double
Easter egg.
While Harley is in Black Mask's captivity,
she briefly loses consciousness.
When she does, she dreams that she's singing
"Diamonds Are a Girl's Best Friend."
Cinephiles will instantly recognize the scene
as a tribute to Marilyn Monroe's performance
in Gentlemen Prefer Blondes.
But there's more going on in that scene, too.
Roman Sionis is also there, and surprisingly,
it's not the first time that Ewan McGregor
has been part of a musical number set to that
one specific song.
Years before Ewan McGregor broke bad in Birds
of Prey, he played the lead in Baz Luhrmann's
Moulin Rouge!, which also featured "Diamonds
Are a Girl's Best Friend."
You might remember the scene when Satine enters
the film for the first time as part of a lavish
musical number, stealing McGregor's heart
forever.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.